let's think about what might happen if
we had a molecule of butanol chloride so
one two three four carbons
that's where the butte comes in and then
it's a butanol chloride so it's an acyl
halide or it's an acyl chloride let me
write this down just to give us some
practice with naming this is butanol
butanol chloride
chloride we saw a couple of videos ago
that acyl halides you just count the
main number of carbons one two three
four carbons that's where the butane
comes from and then this is an acyl
chloride so the acyl chloride part
this part gives us the oil or i guess
you could look at even at the carbonyl
we could even say we could even say this
whole part over here we know it's a
carboxylic acid derivative it's an acyl
chloride so that's why we have the oil
here and the chloride so let's think
about what would happen if we have a
molecule of
butanol chloride if we had a solution
even better of butanol chloride and for
every molecule of butanol chloride we
had two molecules
of
dimethylamide or sorry dimethyl amine
let me draw that so dimethyl so two
methyl groups one
two
and then we have one hydrogen
and then we're gonna have two molecules
of this for every one molecule of our
butanol chloride so let me copy and
paste this
so edit copy and edit paste so let's
think about what would happen in
solution with these with these reactants
in this ratio right now here and just as
a bit of review
this this right here is dimethyl
dimethyl
we kind of have a tie for our longest
chain attached to the nitrogen
dimethylamine
dimethylamine you could pick one of
these as the longest chain and then it
would actually be n-methylmethylamine
either one this is the one that you're
more likely to see but when this video
isn't about naming this video is to
think about what's likely to happen so
what are we dealing with we have an
amine here and then we have an acyl
chloride and if we look at our hierarchy
of stability that we looked at in the
last video
we saw that
what an amine reacts or a carboxylic
derivative from an amine which is an
amide is much more stable than an acyl
chloride this is the least stable so if
we're starting with an acyl chloride
we're starting with an acyl chloride and
we have the ingredients
we have the ingredients for an amide
this reaction will probably end up with
a mead so let's see how that we can get
there
well we know from previous videos when
we studied when we studied amines that
they are pretty good nucleophiles so
they could have a nucleophile attack on
this carbonyl carbon right over here so
you can imagine this amine right here
this nitrogen gives an electron to this
carbonyl carbon this carbonyl carbon can
then let go
of this electron to this top oxygen over
here it was already hogging it to begin
with and so the next step of our
reaction would look like this
what was the butanol chloride will now
look like one two three four carbons now
you only have a single bond this oxygen
up here now has a negative charge since
it took an electron from this central
carbon right over here you are still
bonded to this chlorine and actually let
me do that in a different color so we
can keep track of it
you are still bonded to
this chlorine atom and then the nitrogen
has been bonded so this bond i'll draw
in green because we're giving this green
electron to form the bond and then the
rest of the
dimethylamine is still over there let me
do it in that same color
the rest of the dimethylamine so you
have ch3
ch3 and then you just have your hydrogen
and then this nitrogen gave away an
electron so it has a positive
it has a positive charge now the next
step of this is chlorine you know it it
it it's fairly electronegative it's a
not so bad leaving group it will want to
hog this electron that is on the central
carbon so you can imagine in the next
step that this oxygen gives back an
electron to reform the carbonyl group at
the exact same time that this chlorine
takes an electron and forms a chloride
anion
so the next step in this will look like
so the molecules will now look like you
have their one two three four carbons
that's one of the bonds that oxygen but
now you've now formed another bond
that electron was given back to that
central atom and now you have the bond
to the nitrogen this bond right here
and then the nitrogen is bound to one
methyl group
two methyl groups
and a hydrogen and it had given away an
electron so it has a positive charge and
the chloride
anion has been bumped off
the chlorine anion it took an electron
from that central carbon so now it has a
negative charge
now we still have that other
dimethylamine molecule or for every one
of these we have two of these we've only
used one of them so let me bring the
other one into the mix and this one
could just be in the mix to make this
other
well this other molecule neutral now and
this could go in either direction
this part right here could go in either
direction this guy's a not so weak or
it's not a uh it's not a bad base so
this guy could give an electron to this
hydrogen proton and then the hydrogen
protons electron or that hydrogen atoms
electron can be taken
back by this nitrogen to make it neutral
and i'll make this go in both directions
so this could go in both directions so
then this molecule over here will look
like
one two three four
carbonyl group and let me make let me
color code it the same way just so we
know what parts are what are which parts
we have this green bond to this nitrogen
which has now lost a proton it was able
to take back an electron so it is now
neutral it is bond to one
two
methyl groups
this
dimethylamine
took a hydrogen so let me draw it over
here so it's nitrogen
one
two
and then it has it already had one
hydrogen and now it's gaining another
hydrogen
it's gaining this hydrogen right over
here so now it bound to that hydrogen it
gave an electron to get that hydrogen
nucleus so it now has a positive charge
and of course we can't forget about that
chloride anion that's floating around
that chloride anion that's floating
around and these might be attracted to
each other once positive one's negative
form a salt
so what do we what are we left with and
once again this is a little bit of
practice of naming we started with an
acyl chloride and we ended with an amide
because we we now have this nitrogen
group attached so what is this this has
one two three four carbons so it's
butane
butane but it's an amide so this part
tells us that we're dealing with an
amide that part right butan
it's butanomide but to specify what type
of amide we see that we have two methyl
groups attached to the nitrogen there so
we would call this let me put another
color here we have one two methyl groups
attached to the nitrogen so we would
call this n
comma n
dimethyl
dimethyl butanomine this n lets us this
n comma n lets us know the methyl groups
are attached here as opposed to on the
on the uh the butyl group i guess we
could view it this way so we end up with
nnn dimethyl butanomide which is an
amine one of the most stable carboxylic
acid derivatives and then this right
here this salt what is this
this is
this right here is dimethyl
and this is now no longer dimethyl amine
we now are a positively charged cation
so this is dimethyl ammonium
dimethyl ammonium
ammonium we get that from the fact that
we have four bonds we have a positive
charge this is dimethyl ammonium and
then we have this negative anion
dimethyl ammonium chloride i'll just go
to the next line dimethyl ammonium
chloride but i really just wanted to
show you a mechanism here of how you
could go from
a less stable or one of the least
stables stable carboxylic acid
derivatives to one of the most stables
to going from an acyl chloride which
butanol chloride was to
an amide